he used to be a pro now this 31 year old
manager plays in the amateur league but
he still has one hell of an arm as a kid
he was fascinated with baseball and
started training at an early age he's
playing again today for his club the
raccoons on the outskirts of Moscow more
people are becoming interested in
baseball parents come and watch their
kids play it's not mainstream not like
in the u.s. anyway where games attract
thousands of spectators until a few
years ago American diplomats and
businesspeople used to play here but
after the 2014 Ukraine many of them left
Moscow since then diplomatic relations
between the US and Russia have
deteriorated further something that many
locals were great no more no one in
Russia or the u.s. wants to see the
relationship between our two countries
worse relations between our two
countries will improve then the world
will become more civilized and conflicts
will be resolved in my humane ways yes
I'd like to see the political relations
improve because I'm a community-level
they're good
most recent opinion poll showed that
anti-american sentiment has dropped
drastically in the last few months in
May nearly 70 percent of Russians had a
negative attitude towards the US now
that figure has dropped to just 40
percent two-thirds are in favor of
improving relations with the West Valley
to confront that to me it seems that the
politics of confrontation just isn't
working anymore clearly a trend towards
closer cooperation greater cooperation
and overcoming isolationist thinking
Napa's Virginian Priya daily news alerts
just like in the u.s. tasty snacks are a
must while watching a baseball but
instead of hotdogs here in Moscow
pancakes are on the menu talking
politics during the game is strictly
taboo teams whether at home or abroad
but amateur sports change bilateral
relations either for better or for worse
and that's why the few Russian baseball
fans who come along simply concentrate
on the game